avec l'état hébreu
[Musique]
on va cueillir notre première invitée
c'est carole rousseau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va
[Applaudissements]
quel animateur tu aurais tu te laisser
tenter sur l'île de la tentation
soyez des filles aussi il y avait un
choix de photos
bien menez père menace non sans rigoler
facile parce qu'on se marre où vous
auriez pu vous marrer avec higuain avec
le gorille les chats vous aimez les
tracés salloukh informaticiens ça vous
fait penser sur la compagnie gol non
écoutez si vous danser avec moi pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on a fait une sortie spéciale pour 40
des paroles et/ou pour safari go tout ça
ah ouais je les ai pas entendu je les ai
pas entendus
[Musique]
plutôt yann barthès ou cyril hanouna
cette heure là ni l'autre c'est
malhonnête parce que j'ai dit qu'à cette
heure là j'étais en train de m'occuper
de mes enfants je regardais jamais la
télé à 19 heures quand j'ai juste besoin
d'envoyer un message au président c'est
normal carole rousseau et émane pas vous
êtes bas merci carole rousseau merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur six mois je
décide de rien carole elle a trouvé un
talon ah oui c'est vrai c'est faire les
les fonds
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais je voi alerte morandini gens là
c'est énorme
la drame la marque a émis une alerte
carole rousseau tu sais très bien
[Musique]